jeff's in daytona beach hi jeff how are
you
i'm doing well sir how are you doing
real happy to be on the phone with you
you too sir how can we help so i have a
question
my wife and i are looking to install a
pool in our backyard and
i i know your your your thoughts on on
pools and
and getting refinancing to use the money
for that but
just a little bit about my wife and i
have lived very financially responsible
we have uh no debt cars are paid off we
have college
funds for the kids we maxed out both
roth iras
we're also both pension employees uh
with the city here so we have a pension
to look forward to
and we have deferred comp um
we bought our we currently owe 134
on our home our interest rate is 4.125
what do you do what do you need you're
doing great man i'm talking you're doing
wonderful i know yes
how can i help so we are wanting to
install a pool in our backyard we have
two young kids
we are in what we consider our forever
home and we are wanting to refinance the
house
and pull 60 000 out of the house
to install the pool you want to put a
sixty thousand dollar house in a hundred
sixty thousand dollar pool and a hundred
thirty thousand dollar house
so no we only owe a hundred and thirty
five oh i'm sorry what's the house worth
what's the house worth
one third or i'm sorry 330.
and the new rate week yep the new rate
we could get would be 2.375
i said that's an expensive pool
yeah oh yeah 60 000 is an expensive pool
that's uh
that's that's my wife's doing and that's
a that's uh
it is yeah it's hard doing you're the
one calling jeff
i i know it it it would be a very nice
pool
and i know it's expensive but like i
said we are not planning on on going
anywhere
at least until the kids are through high
school so that's about another 13 years
you know for the youngest one
okay um well what what you're
very clearly describing over and over
and over again
and you've said it six different ways is
that you know this is an irresponsible
bad idea
yeah but you're trying you're but you're
trying to make me think it's okay
so that so that you're gonna think it's
okay so that they will say
you're you're on to me i mean it's just
it's
um okay let's walk through it so number
one i'm not against fun
number two you have done a great job
with your finances congratulations
number three you have a clue where you
are you know exactly what's going on
you're not
a wandering generality you're not out of
control
you're you're very systematized you've
been very
uh beautifully done you've told me your
numbers you're not you're not guessing
you know exactly where you are so you
have a lot of positive things going on
and and then you have this uh your
stomach is in your throat because you're
getting ready to pay
too much for a pool for a 330 000
house it doesn't make sense to put that
nice a pool on a house
that expense meaning you would never
recoup it
ever you're you're over building the
neighborhood you
have to be by definition even if there's
pools all up and down your street
they're not sixty thousand dollar pools
and three hundred thousand dollar houses
people don't do that that is true okay
so number one you know you're spending
too much number two you're borrowing
money to buy a fun
toy yes and you know that that's not
unwise
and um you called the guy that was would
tell you both of those things right i
mean
what what do you want how can i help you
could i could i run something by you you
think it's going to change my mind
i don't know
i try that technique jeff with my
husband all the time well let me just
give you one more
all right let's try let's let's try it
let's try it you're a good sport jeff
let's try it for fun here
so my wife and i we purchased the home
we've been in the home about six years
we purchased it for a hundred and sixty
thousand dollars
it has appraised quite a bit i i i
understand
so the new if we were to refinance
um at a lower rate of 2.37 we would have
that
the the mathematic equation you give out
we would with the closing cost which is
about nine thousand dollars we
would cover that in about three years
we're going to be in the home for at
least
i'd say at least 10 to 15 years and with
the refinance we're only refinancing at
210 uh 210 thousand dollars
which is still substantially less than
what all the homes and you think it's
going to make you bankrupt
okay yeah i don't think you're going to
go out of business because of this
i don't think you're going to completely
you know get a divorce because of
financial stress that's not that's not
what i'm saying
i'm saying hey you're borrowing money to
buy a toy
truck even though you figured out some
bass awkward sophisticated way to make
it sound okay
but you're still borrowing money to buy
a toy and
you're over building your neighborhood
both okay
so if you want to do if you want to do
one
if you want to do one of those over
build the neighborhood
okay so don't but don't borrow the money
to do it
gotcha so i and i so i i
if i woke up in your shoes i would do
one of two things
uh and is do you have any money to put
towards this project
we would we have twenty thousand dollars
that we would put uh
towards but the way pools are built ever
i mean it's such a hot commodity here in
the state of florida right now that
they're putting an 80 000 pool in oh
jeff you're in more trouble now
oh it's a 60 000 pool oh okay so you're
borrowing
you're going to borrow 40. yes sir i'm
sorry
okay no i'm misunderstood i'm
misunderstood okay so you got 20.
so if you and what's your household
income
about 110 000 phenomenal okay
i would project that based on the fact
that you two actually have done so good
until we got to this conversation with
your finances
that the two of you could add another
twenty thousand to this twenty thousand
very quickly
and pay cash for a forty thousand dollar
pool if dave and sharon ramsey were in
your shoes
that's exactly what we would do yes sir
i'm going to tell my wife we're going to
have to eliminate sushi sunday
and that's that big no more it's up to
you it's not a lemonade
it's trade we're trading it for a pool
you eat a lot of sushi apparently but i
was waiting for that but
but your trade you know you're going to
eliminate some lifestyle to get the pool
that's what dave and sharon ramsey would
do
we've but we've got some nice toys in
our life and i remember
the first time we bought a toy we bought
a little bitty dinky butt house on the
lake for a hundred thousand dollars and
we thought it was the
oh god we just bought a second house
we're like rich people or something we
have two houses
it was a hundred thousand hundred three
thousand 000
and but we pay cash for it and we've
never regretted it
we've never regretted owning a lake
house because we pay cash for our toys
and they don't come back to bite you in
the butt later